there's no shortage of brexit errs in
the conservative party leadership
contest so not be someone from the more
remained wing off the party in the race
joining us now is the former education
secretary justin greening morning so
first question are you gonna run no I
think this is a beauty parade for hard
brexit ears so I'm not gonna be in it
and is that the reason why you just
don't think there's effectively any
chance that you would win I think this
should and could have been a leadership
contest that was about hard choices to
the conservative party how are we going
to resolve brexit how are we going to
make sure we reach out to a new
generation of conservative voters who
are currently switched off this party
instead it is really just going to be a
beauty parade of hard brexit ears I
don't think we're going to be talking
about the hard choices we need to be so
because of that I'm not gonna be in it
at the same time now can you really
complain about the what the race is
about if you're not willing to get in
there and make your arguments I think
you just have to face the reality of
where the party's at at the moment I
don't know whether you know I've not won
the case on a second referendum as a
resolution yet there may well be a time
when when we do realize that that's the
right route through but I think I'm not
into pointless exercises and for me
actually this is a much more positive
choice about continuing the social
mobility pledge campaign or the work
that I'm doing on the ground with
businesses working in schools helping to
create more opportunities for young
people and I just genuinely feel like my
time is better spent on that and it's
more productive and change is actually
happening outside of Parliament because
it's so gridlocked on Parliament on
brexit so for me I'd rather positively
and actively stay working on that on
solutions and making a difference on the
ground than being part of a narrow
discussion in a narrow conservative
party that is really around what version
of hard brexit to do which I think
anyway is a bad idea
how do you think boaters will how do you
think they will judge the campaign that
we're seeing now well I think what we
should be doing is talking to people out
in the country and instead we're about
to spend several weeks having a
discussion with ourselves at a moment
when the country
is in crisis now what I want to hear
from those people who set their face
against a second referendum as a way of
resolving brakes is what's their plan I
think we're getting a lot of them so
they want to leave with no deal by the
end which is not going to get through
Parliament a soft brexit deal the Prime
Minister proposed doesn't get through
Parliament none of them need to all of
them need to set out the detail of how
they are going to do a workable
deliverable route forward on brick's
it's not just what they want how are
they going to implement it and they now
have not only the opportunity but I
think the duty to explain to the British
people as well as conservative party
members what their solutions are on
brakes and how they're actually going to
find a viable route through because my
judgment is that Parliament is
gridlocked and it's going to stay
gridlocked so we will have to have a
referendum because it's the only the
people who can now break that gridlock
you had written a piece in The Observer
today and you say you see the
Conservative Party engaging in a debate
with itself about what type of electoral
cyanide just to take I mean what do you
mean by that
it sounds pretty grim well whilst we're
failing to find a route forward on
brexit all the other issues that people
around the country actually want solved
like improving social mobility housing
social care the environment seem to be
getting set on one side and the entire
political bandwidth of Parliament and
government is on brexit we've seen that
over the last two three years we've not
been doing other stuff than brexit so
until you have a route through we won't
be able to break that logjam and what
I'm saying to the candidates is tell us
what the route is I recognise that
people are not yet convinced that a
second referendum is the way to break
the logjam but I want to hear what their
alternative is because so far I haven't
seen it we has from Damien green a bit
early on the program and he said that he
thinks the future of the Conservative
Party is at stake here I mean is that
what you think well I think if we keep
picking making wrong choices failing to
make decisions about tough choices
failing to see that we're now not even
the most compelling party on brexit for
voters who want breaks it that's now the
brexit party I think you'll see that
probably in the European Union election
results tomorrow whilst at the same time
we're not reaching out to young people
we're not willing to listen to
communities like my own full of young
people who are saying that they want to
say on BRICS and actually they see
brexit as the thing that's holding up
change happening in Britain and for me
whilst this debate myopically goes on in
the Conservative Party I'd much rather
put my time into actively positively
constructively working on the ground to
genuinely get more opportunity to more
young people and I think the days of
thinking any way that government fixes
everything in this country I think
that's old politics I think change
happens outside of Parliament now and
that's where I'm going to put my time
you can aback well I want to see all the
candidates set out there stall so it's
impossible to say and there's something
you've ruled out okay I not yet know I
mean obviously I'll I'll genuinely look
at what they all have to say but I won't
see some details and viable serious
proper plans for Britain I mean we've
already heard from several contenders
Boris Johnson Donna trauma-based
McVeigh's saying that they are prepared
to take the UK out of the EU without a
deal at the end of October if that
became conservative government policy
would you vote against the government in
a confidence motion well I think
Parliament will stop government doing
that well and again it's just simply not
everybody knows motion strategy I think
that I think the part I think Parliament
has now voted against No Deal several
times it is clear that communities for
the most part do not want to leave the
European Union with no deal but to stop
no do you might have to be prepared to
bring down the government would you be
prepared to do that I think I think the
the danger is the a government with a an
unviable strategy on breck C is
destabilizing itself and this is why the
sooner I think the MPs in Parliament
that members
the Conservative Party recognized that
that's what's at stake for not finding a
viable route through Parliament through
brexit and the choice is going to be
quite simple I think maybe you're right
either we end up with a general election
which Jeremy Corbyn would likely win I
don't think he'll win it with a majority
he's likely to have a coalition partner
who's likely to demand some kind of a
second referendum or we can choose to
break the brexit deadlock through
actually giving people a vote but on the
topic itself which is a second
referendum on brexit and in the end we
are going to have to buy the bullet but
for the moment it seems to me that the
parties avoiding those tough choices and
that's why for the the leadership
campaign I'm not going to be part of it
now while we've got you on keen to ask
you about school funding I've been doing
looking at this on the program today you
of course a former education secretary
have schools got enough money I think
they do need more money I was the last
education secretary to put more money
into the system 1.3 billion but key to
this frankly is less the DfE and more
the Treasury you know when you do a
package on education and schools you
should be going to the Treasury for a
comment on whether they're planning to
allow the DfE to have more investment to
pump into schools fundamentally though
you need a strategy that isn't just
about the money that that's how you
finance it the strategy should be as
Michael Wilshaw talked about lifting up
schools in those parts of the country
where schools performance hasn't been as
good really working to make sure that
those children who are every bit as
talented as children growing up in parts
of the country was with better schools
that they get that best start as well in
our education system is it issues like
education that could end up giving
during Auburn the case number turn do
you think well there's no doubt that our
unwillingness to tackle school funding
and the concerns parents had on it at
the last election did cost us voice